Google Cloud update what a whirlwind
we're back from next and we're working
on some recap content for you there was
a lot to cover so make sure that you
check out any content that you missed on
demand or via recap on our YouTube
channel and we'll be updating these
weekly for the rest of the year so get
excited just before next we released a
new suite of environmental apis solar
air quality and pollen and these apis
help developers better understand an
ever-changing world so they can create
new sustainability tools share
actionable insights check them out on
the blog to learn more thanks for
joining us for this week's